let me read through what this is it
looks very arbitrator it's actually very
easy to read once you know what to look
for okay so here's my three by three
matrix when you see instead of the
regular square brackets you're used to
when you see these lines going down the
sides which some of you might recognize
is also meaning absolute value they meet
a lot of things okay that means the
determinant of a right so the
determinant of this 3 by 3 matrix think
about this Sun 2 by 2 matrix and how we
worked it up okay what you did was you
kind of did this cross pattern okay so
it was a D that 1 minus B see that one
okay so the way to work it out for is
this you might be able to see the
pattern okay is you have to work out the
three of them okay so you start with
this top one okay and you look at this
little 2 by 2 matrix that it creates
okay so see how if I look at this then
this is the opposites kind of 2 by 2 in
that little corner okay so now you work
out the determinant of that like so but
that's not all you keep going okay just
like in matrix multiplication right so
now I've done the a so I'm going to move
over and do the be okay yeah you shift
it one across but look see this matrix
when they get this from 0 go yeah I got
it from these two that's what forced by
2 by 2 you work out the determinant of
that and then you go over to the end and
you've got another little square here
two bites you there is deg H and then
you work out yeah that's exactly and
then you it just is okay
do you watch out for the alternating
science by the way
now here's the thing menos vide will say
well why are you doing it that way
and the answer is if I try this thing
and I went ahead and worked out its
volume this is what it would be so there
has to be subtraction here and plus and
subtraction and it would keep going if I
to bigger matrix